Віцеадмірал і командувач ВМФ Німеччини Кай-Ахім Шенбах закінчив кар'єру швидко та безславно.
22 січня 56-річний офіцер подав у відставку, вибачившись за свої слова про Крим та Володимира Путіна.
Напередодні на конференції в Індії Шенбах заявив буквально таке:
… Але чого Путін хоче насправді, то це поваги. Відносин на рівних.
І, Боже ти мій, продемонструвати повагу до когось нічого не коштує.
Це ж так просто - продемонструвати комусь повагу, якої він вимагає і, ймовірно, заслуговує.
(...) Росія - стара країна і важлива країна теж, і навіть ми, Індія та Німеччина, потребуємо Росії - у протистоянні з Китаєм.
(... ) А щодо Криму, то він втрачений і ніколи не повернеться. Це факт, із яким нам треба жити.
Реакція міністерства оборони Німеччини була швидкою та рішучою. Воно категорично дистанціювалося від слів Шенбаха.
А сам віцеадмірал вибачився у "Твіттері", назвавши свої висловлювання такими,
що не відображають позицію міністерства оборони, є необдуманими та помилковими.
Командувач ВМФ подав прохання про відставку – і воно було негайно задоволене.
Посол України в Німеччині Андрій Мельник у "Твіттері" привітав відставку віцеадмірала, проте назвав її -
буквально - "недостатньою для повного відновлення довіри до німецької політики".
Уряд Німеччини, за словами Мельника, має змінити курс щодо Києва.
Посол, вочевидь, має на увазі відмову Німеччини постачати зброю в Україну.
Однозначною була реакція фракції ХДС у Бундестазі.
Експерт із зовнішньої політики Юрґен Гардт в інтерв'ю газеті "Вельт" наголосив, що висловлювання віцеадмірала жодним чином не відповідають позиції уряду.
І додав: "Крим - це частина України".
А представник Зелених Омід Нуріпур з розумінням поставився до обурених реакцій української влади.
На урядовій пресконференції 24 січня у Берліні ситуацію прокоментували так:
Федеральний уряд однозначно дистанціюється від висловлювань командувача ВМФ, зроблених у п'ятницю.
Це не позиція федерального уряду.
В уряду чітка позиція, особливо в тому, що стосується Криму й дотримання міжнародного права. І ця позиція не підлягає сумнівам.
З погляду міністерства оборони прохання про звільнення від обов'язків - це єдиний правильний крок.
Міністерка оборони сьогодні зустрілася з ним особисто. Вона подякувала йому за службу і побажала йому всього доброго.
Відставка командувача військово-морським флотом Німеччини відразу після його резонансних заяв про Крим
засвідчила, що у питанні територіальної приналежності Криму позиція німецького уряду залишається незмінною.
Водночас німецький канцлер соціал-демократ Олаф Шольц вчергове застеріг Москву від ескалації конфлікту.
Військова агресія дорого обійдеться (Росії). Яких заходів буде вжито, буде погоджено між країнами-союзниками й оголошено.
Зараз ми готуємо відповідні заходи, щоб ухвалити конкретне рішення.
За словами представника фракції Зелених у Бундестазі Юрґена Тріттіна, Росія має зрозуміти,
що порушення територіальної цілісності України матиме масштабні наслідки.
… Йдеться (про припинення) не одного чи двох проєктів, а про співпрацю в цілому.
Тобто про політичні та економічні відносини між Росією та Європою…
Так, ми залежимо від Росії, але це взаємна залежність.
Російська економічна модель, та навіть російська модель управління ґрунтується на експорті копалин.
Так що всі ці (двосторонні) відносини будуть під питанням. Ось такий меседж має отримати Путін.
Говорячи про "дорогу ціну" агресії, Берлін, однак, поки не озвучує можливих санкцій щодо Росії.
І якщо США погрожують заблокувати запуск "Північного потоку-2", а також відключити РФ
від міжнародної фінансової системи Swift, уряд Німеччини ці заходи не підтримує.